you're looking at a table which
describes one two three four different
clients of loans and gives you all of
the different sort of itty-bitty details
on like what are the advantages and
disadvantages of each one okay so some
of them are really easy to identify for
example I would maybe put asterisks
about you next to this one and this one
these are probably the most important
mathematically because you're going to
be crunching those numbers you're going
to be multiplying those by the principle
you're going to be a of each month that
table that you drew up yesterday with me
of like what's the balance now what am I
going up to six months of repayment in
that case all those things of factors so
those are the obvious ones and I don't
think um I don't think I need to explain
what those are to you but then there's
all the rest of this stuff so we'll
begin at the top because that's the
simplest establishment fee by the name
what do you think that means okay just
to get started just to get your foot in
the door right
your establishment fee is just a lump
sum that at the beginning of your
mortgage or loan or whatever it is you
just have to pay that just for the
privilege of borrowing money off of them
okay you can see there's not much there
for their comparisons yeah they're all
charging you a pretty similar amounts
there's not that much competition on
them okay I will point out maybe you
want to UM underneath underneath your
heading that you've written you might
see this French phrase a lot in an
adverse man for a bank that's trying to
steal customers from other banks because
that's the easiest way to make money
right there's lots of people out there
they've got a mortgage they've got a
loan and if you can convince them to
come to you then that's gonna be really
powerful for you what they'll do is
they'll say a little asterisks or
sometimes big asterisk will waive your
establishment fee right what does waive
me get rid of what they'll do is I said
okay look you're on the super one right
now
thank you if you come over to our bank
we will pay the establishment fee for
you so they're trying to encourage you
they're trained incentivize you to move
over to them does that make sense okay
all right let's keep going
additional repayments now have a look at
what the options are on the right hand
side for additional repayments what is
this about
is this me
what are we payments just I mean there's
a really obvious question for human me
okay this is what you're paying back
every month basically and if you do
exactly what they expect you to pay what
you agree to you'll take 25 years 30
years you agree to the term of the loan
okay but suppose you like with the
lottery or you get a raise and you're
like hey I have access to more funds now
you're gonna think to yourself it's
probably good if I can pay more money
off sooner why is that by the way why
don't just wait good the longer you're
in the loan the more interest they're
gonna charge you so and especially do
you remember when we drew up that table
at the beginning of your line they're
charging you heaps of interest if you
can reduce that amount reducing balance
that's really good
okay so you can see additional
repayments that's not a given you can
see it over here on the right hand side
see now what over there look at the name
this is a fixed loan okay so they're
like look the agreement on which we've
set this up is know who's not gonna let
you make additional repayments why why
because they want to calculate more
interest on you right so you can see you
can have a look at the other features
they're going to have other things that
are going to track to you over to that
maybe you know based on your income
they're like no look we're not even
going to let you have the option of
considering these other ones you have to
get this okay you can also see this this
one with you so they're like yeah we
alum will take some repayments but only
a certain amount right they'll limit the
number of extra repayments you do
because every additional repayment you
make is interest they don't get to
charge you does this make sense okay so
maybe underneath your heading of on
comparing loans right when you say
additional repayments
I would define that as is the bank going
to allow
you to reduce the balance more than what
was agreed to okay let me say that again
it's a pretty important phrase is the
bank going to allow you to reduce the
balance with additional repayments more
than what you originally had on your
contract that you signed on okay
and obviously it's your in your interest
to do that one more time
additionally payments what it means is
will the bank allow you to reduce your
balance further than what you originally
agreed to right so do you remember the
previous example the table 1888 dollars
they're going to get that from you every
month and basically you're saying well
can i if I want to pay more than that
that'll allow me to pay off the loan
faster that's good for me not so good
for the bank so they may or may not
allow you together okay okay cool let's
move let's move down the lists redraw
free redraw or fee right
what redraw refers to you should
definitely write this down redraw what
redraw refers to use when you are paying
off your loan when you're paying off
your loan maybe you start off and you're
like I owe the bank two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars okay which is a
lot of money now here's a thing you've
got to go through an approval process
for this remember I said to you before
I'm borrowing money right when you
borrow money from the bank basically
they're kind of like investing in you
does that make sense they're like
handing you a sum of money a big sum of
money and letting you use it for
whatever purpose now you imagine
yourself as an investor if you're an
investor you're not just going to invest
in any old company out there right what
are you going to do how are you going to
choose who you invest in
you want a stable company you want maybe
a company that's actually going to grow
is not like an industry that's like okay
don't invest in blockbuster those kinds
of things so you're gonna choose
carefully right you're gonna choose cash
now being that the bank is investing in
you they're going to choose carefully as
well so they do these things for credit
checks they don't know what a credit
check it is what's it anyway
so your creditors your creditors right
they're people who have lent you money
in the past and they're gonna have a
record oh yeah yeah Akhil paid back his
debts all the time everything was fine
he has a really good credit rating as
opposed to mr. blue like goodness I had
to chase him so hard
it didn't even pay it or laughs it was a
disaster so they do this kind of thing
I think they check that they check what
your current income is whether you have
a permanent or temporary job here's a
thing right
there for what they've done is maybe
just put this underneath because it's
kind of appoint the credit check what it
does is it leads to you being approved
for a loan of a certain size okay now as
you can imagine the more you're earning
the more stable your job is the better
your credit history the larger loan size
they're happy to approve you for okay so
now just imagine you're the bank and
you're like yeah you know Emily's fine
I'll grant her - and $50,000 she's
trustworthy now once you start payment
off let's imagine that's fast forward
five years of the future you've paid off
the chunk of money and you're like I
want to borrow more from that right I've
paid off this money absolutely but can I
for it back out like I know I've been
handing it to you because I'm in debt to
you but can I draw it out a second time
can I redraw from you okay so redraw as
you can see above but everyone's gonna
let you do redraw right because redraw
is kind of like think of you you're the
bank you're like actually I'm kind of
happy that you've paid me off I don't
borrow from me again that's why some of
these don't let you have redraw did you
see that they like the no no no you paid
it off
that money's back in my hands thank you
very much you want to get another loan
fine we can reinvestigate but these guys
want this one will it's the most
expensive of them you can see and then
have a look at this one what's this big
yeah so you can see they're like redraw
represents financial risk for them right
so therefore they're like well if you
want to do it fine but we're not gonna
make it easy for you we would charge you
for that privilege okay does that make
sense so redraw is about making
withdrawals making withdrawals after
repaying the debt so it's kind of like
hey can I make my debt go back up to
what it was before
that's essentially what you're doing all
right and it's it's founded on this idea
of the credit check that if we um if we
checked you before and we gave you a
thumbs-up then if we're willing if you
have the right plan will allow you to go
back up to that debt level because we're
we're sort of um we know you're reliable
enough to paid off yes but only to a
certain extent because like let's just
imagine go to the the nth degree I could
just keep on redrawing and redrawing and
redrawing and they're like great but you
know the principle of you never sue
someone unless they've got something you
can gain from them well there's no point
they're charging me turist if I'm never
gonna pay them off I'm just gonna file
for bankruptcy in five years and then
all the debt is gone right so therefore
like well yes I can guess what it does
to your credit rating yeah so so
obviously you don't want to go there but
people do people the companies declare
bankruptcy all the time because they're
like we've racked up these huge amounts
of debts and we just physically can't
pay them off we take out we take out
loans to repay our loans and then we run
out of people who are willing to give us